well over the weekend I was looking at
my mutual fund account to see how things
went in May and it is very very ugly one
of the worst months other than October
of 2018 and December of 2018 one of the
worst months ever for my mutual fund
account and part of it was this
precipitous market decline that happened
at the end of May because of Donald
Trump escalating the world trade war
again this time by announcing new
tariffs on Mexico which are quite
frankly absolutely ridiculous and I'm
gonna explain to you exactly why today
the markets are realizing effectively
that Donald Trump really is this dumb
Donald Trump really is this ignorant
about basic economics and trade and it
is really getting ugly out there in the
economic sense Donald Trump as you might
know and we've talked about started a
trade war with China and we've gotten
nothing substantive out of it and it has
been a disaster for American companies
and American taxpayers American
companies and taxpayers not China have
paid billions in extra dollars as a
result of Donald Trump's tariffs on
China five trillion dollars has
disappeared in value from the stock
market there is no credible off-ramp
from these tariffs anytime soon meaning
away for Trump to get us out of them and
to sort of de-escalate and go back to
where we were before and in the meantime
China continues to simply make other
arrangements China's making deals with
Russia on energy China's doing more
trade with other countries and what does
Donald Trump decide to do he decides to
start another trade war this time with
Mexico Trump announcing obviously on
Twitter where else is he going to do it
that there will be a five percent tariff
on Mexican goods until illegal
immigrants stopped coming to the US and
that five percent could escalate
significantly Donald Trump tweeting
quote On June 10th the United States
will impose a five percent tariff on all
goods coming into our country from
Mexico until such time as illegal
migrants coming through Mexico
and into our country stop the tariff
will gradually increase until the
illegal immigration problem is remedied
at which time the tariffs will be
removed details from the White House to
follow what Donald Trump is saying is
that Americans will be paying 5% more
for Mexican Goods and Trump later
followed this up by saying that the five
percent becomes 10 percent quote if the
crisis persists and then there would be
an additional five percentage points
each month for three months getting all
the way up to potentially according to
the president a twenty five percent
tariff on Mexican goods coming to the
United States this is true real idiocy
you know sometimes I look a search hard
for the right words to use to describe
economic policy or socio-cultural policy
or political decisions this is just
idiocy and it's actually getting so
stupid that even many Republicans are
saying this is a bad idea the horribly
depraved disgusting Republican ideologue
Chuck Grassley even has the sense to say
that these Mexico tariffs are a misuse
of presidential authority but there's
something truly mind-blowing and and
just dumb about this the point here is
that Donald Trump wants to hurt Mexico
with this policy right Donald Trump
doesn't like what he sees as Mexican I
guess indifference when it comes to
undocumented immigration from Mexico to
the United States so he wants to hurt
Mexico now let's put aside for a second
that there's a net outflow of
immigration to Mexico even accounting
for undocumented that most of the people
that are coming in over the border many
of the people are actually coming from
countries further south than Mexico so
really we should be dealing with the
economic situations in those countries
if you actually want to reduce the
demand of those citizens to go through
Mexico and try to get into the United
States put all of that stuff aside Trump
wants to hurt Mexico with this policy if
Trump succeeds in hurting Mexico with
these new tariffs that will make the
Mexican economic situation worse
which will create
a demand for more Mexicans to try to
come to the United States legally and
illegally which is what Donald Trump is
trying to stop these tariffs are
completely counterproductive we've gone
from Mexico is definitely going to pay
for the wall - Mexico is not paying for
the wall and now there isn't even a wall
- we are going to put tariffs on
avocados and cars and all of the stuff
that comes from Mexico we're gonna make
that more expensive for Americans while
potentially increasing the motivation
that Mexicans will have to come to the
United States illegally I thought we
were told that businessman president
genius Trump was gonna bring us economic
prosperity we were told that this is
some kind of complex 4d chess that
Donald Trump is executing on trade which
many of his followers during the
campaign who by the way know nothing
about trade people who know nothing
about trade fell hook line and sinker
for the idea that Donald Trump knew how
to fix it it's not happening this is
triggering the possibility of a
recession and that probability keeps
growing a second trump term could be
utterly devastating to the economy of
this type of completely uninformed
tariff policy continues and the most
important and stunning thing about this
is that both Donald Trump and his
followers and some people who aren't his
followers to be quite fair and full
don't understand that when you tariffs
China or Mexico they don't pay for it
the importing companies and people in
the United States are the ones that pay
for it now I I don't want to ignore the
sort of economic theory behind the
tariff the the idea is that even though
strictly speaking the tariff is paid by
the importing countries companies and
individuals if we bring avocados from
Mexico to the US and they have a 5%
tariff it's the u.s. importer that pays
the 5% which they pass along to the
consumer so avocados end up costing 5%
more the economic theory behind it is if
you let's imagine that American avocados
are 3% more expensive than Mexican
avocados if you put a five percent
tariff on the Mexican avocado the idea
would be you will boost local business
because you now have the option of
either Mexican avocados with a five
percent tariff on top or American
avocados which are only three percent
more expensive these are imaginary
numbers so you would shift consumption
from the Mexican avocado to the American
avocado the problem is that we are
starting to tariff items that are not
the the you can't easily shift
production in the way that would be
required for it to work in that way when
we're talking about aluminum and steel
from China which are building materials
that are you don't just switch your
supplier overnight companies don't have
that flexibility they're not nimble in
that way when there is a certain demand
for avocados that's based on the fact
that we are getting them from Mexico you
can't just put a five percent tariff on
avocados and all of a sudden it's all
American avocados that everybody's
buying the supply is not there it takes
a while to grow these things cars it
takes a while if you're buying cars that
are built in Mexico and a tariff gets
placed on them
you can't immediately shift production
in order to account for that in a way
that will work the way Trump maybe
believes it would work so we're gonna
dig into that more after the break but
once again markets are realizing Trump
doesn't know what the hell is going on
with these tariffs let me know what you
think I'm on Twitter at D Pakman the
show is on twitter at david pakman show
today's sponsor is Skillshare and i'm
excited to tell you that everybody in
our audience is getting two entire
months of free access to Skillshare when
you click the link underneath this video
skill shares the site that offers over
25,000 online courses on almost any
topic you can imagine cooking meditation
photography video editing Photoshop
managing a small business almost an
endless list and whether you're trying
to get ahead in your career maybe you
want to learn new skills that will make
you better at your job you might just be
exploring a new hobby and you're trying
to find new ways to be creative in your
personal time skill shares the perfect
place to fully immerse yourself in
whatever you're trying to learn I really
enjoyed the class on more advanced video
editing techniques because it's
something I've been wanting to improve
at but have been very busy posting the
david packard show for the last few
years
once again the david pakman show is
giving you two whole months of access to
every single class offered by Skillshare
after those two months if you want to
keep your subscription Skillshare super
affordable at less than ten bucks a
month get better at whatever it is that
you're passionate about or discover
something brand new that you didn't even
know that you would love and join skill
shares other 7 million users by clicking
the link underneath this video
[Music]